the viral charger Super Fan has a secret
and it has to do with her being a fake
fan but not in the way you think let's
get the backstory first though Mar and
doe caught the camera's attention during
the Chargers Monday night game for her
extremely passionate reactions the
cameras loved her and so did the
internet the Chargers even changed their
ex profile picture to her face but then
she went on the Pat McAfee show and she
admitted that she is also a Vikings fan
how does that work well she's originally
from Minnesota and moved to California
20 years ago and even though she is now
a hardcore charger fan clearly she still
has love for the Vikings and while a lot
of you might say you can only pick one
team she's doing her and she's having a
great time doing it